se hisser dans les airs et planer aux
commandes d'un paramoteur d'un
pendulaires ou d'un multi axes autant de
modèles pour un même plaisir
l'intérêt du lm c'est comme si une
machine qui n'est pas certifié on peut
faire des modifications
sous la responsabilité du constructeur
ou de l'utilisateur sans passer par les
services officiels et donc de rendre la
machine accessible aux personnes
porteuses de handicap moteur ou
sensoriel comme ce modèle où les
commandes sont adaptés le pédalier est
remplacé par un mal aux niçois veut dire
qu'avec deux mains gauches coup droit
tout fait la même chose comme pilote qui
à deux mains et des pieds
victime d'une paralysie temporaire alors
s'est tourné vers lui à l'aim pour
continuer à voler une liberté qu'il
offre depuis à d'autres via
l'association handi vol par la pratique
de l'ue elle aime ce sont les regards
sur le handicap qu'il espère changer
souvent quand je suis sur un aérodrome
jeu voiture second fait le vide autour
de jours les gens nous évite comme
niveau des personnes en fauteuil on veut
changer cette image ou une personne
handicapée qui pilote elle est comme
tous les pilotes et quel que soit le
handicap
typhaine est déficiente visuelle et
marine bien sûr profonde depuis sa
naissance grâce à leur association elles
ont réussi à s'accepter
ça a permis de montrer que le handicap
n'est pas un frein et en en passant par
l'avion et lui elle m du coup bah c'est
ça nous permet de le défricher le
terrain défriché le terrain pour
d'autres les ambitions devenir la
première astronaute sourde sur la lune
c1 c'est un rêve depuis depuis que j'ai
9 encore entre le ciel et l'espace lui
allait mener qu'une étape les jeunes
pilotes ont candidaté au prix de l'
agence spatiale européenne dans la
catégorie par astronaute